we got Justin Bieber here you can tell
he's played before okay that's that's
impressive I've never seen anyone do
this thing before I mean that's not easy
to do I mean that's actually pretty good
that's actually kind of sick Picture
Perfect you don't even need a filter bro
throwing in some headers as well that's
pretty good techers okay yeah he's
pretty techy there's a lot of
professional players that couldn't do
that I didn't expect that from Justin it
was a good effort he had some control
but such has got a bit sporadic at some
point he's got some room for improvement
all right so this is Drake oh and I
spent what's up going on very strong
I'll give it a 10 out of 10. decent
little finish the celebration definitely
hyped it up a bit more I was expecting a
really powerful finish I think if any
decent Keepers saving that I don't like
the beginning of his run-up I mean score
which is the most important nobody
really cares how you did it I mean he
scored and that's what really matters in
the day but I'm not sure about the
technique I like the confidence he
buried the pen and the keeper gets the
right side so it's good no no that
wouldn't happen to me I hope not